l'ida vous avez connu donc tarek sur
l'émission hanoune ait sur canal+ voilà
il vous a choisis et est ce que vous
l'avez revu après ouais mais je l'aï
revu il est revu et adore le soir même
on s'est revu très rapidement après
l'émission c'était quel que soit après
ouais et je t'avoue que je trouve ça un
peu mais on va en reparler
je cois part mais je croyais que
mais c'est vrai mais je vais parce que
alors non plus celle là du tout allé
chez lui non mais je vais expliquer la
soirée en fait ce que vous êtes allé
chez lui oui mais non avant sa grâce à
toi d'ailleurs je dois marcher on a été
dîner dans un restaurant de khales
investi mais qu'elle s'appelle le bambou
âge à l'hippopotamus moi
non je voyais à vue tout nu je pense que
vous allez au bambou
et donc oui et elle dont claudine était
très sympa on a bu un verre oui qui boit
pas
et à la suite de ça donc il m'a proposé
une continue la soirée chez lui comme
d'hab j'habite au
bas de la ville la ville dans la ville
où je continue je vais l'agresser
d'avoir kaboul sommes d'accord ça c'est
vrai
qu est-ce qu est-ce qu est-ce qu on peut
rire décrire l'appartement ben pas de
souci du coup quand on entre directement
à la porte à droite ça une salle de bain
c'est une bonne
c'est tout qui a dit non non non non
plus jouer derrière il précise qu'il a
des bon goût en des coûts puisque c'est
tout en noir et blanc c'est sympa mais
c'est une vingtaine d'hectares avec si
vous avez emmené cette jeune fille
chelsea
parfait à quel point m
est ce que cette fille est ce que c'est
vrai ou pas si ce n'est un mois là je
suis fâché son appel en est sortie de
l'émission il m'a dit qu'il la trouvait
vraiment mignonne et après c'est vrai
que monsieur
et je lui en veux parce qu'il m'a pas
raconté la fondation il m'a juste dit
qu'il a très très mignonne bataille
non non non je vous jure c'est on ne vit
que sarah cas arrêtez votre vie d'ardeur
aujourd'hui quand on s'en fout mais du
coup je le prends assez mal en fait et
donc j'avais passé la soirée ce texte-là
soirée chez lui donc ouais on a passé la
soirée donc on a un qu'on a repris 1,20
on a pas mal discuté et pas mal
d'ailleurs de cinéma oui et j'avais
promis que je montre ouvert la salsa du
conte à danser la salsa c'est nous mêmes
ah non mais regarde même qu on a dansé
autour de ta sculpture bizarre en bois
la
turquie a dit qu'il y avait ça chez moi
mais c'est pas vrai j'ai alors vous êtes
parti et vous avez passé la nuit chez
l'une a tué enceinte
le feeling passe et bien il faut croire
que sa pulka et du coup
une chose en amène une autre il m'a
demandé de passer la nuit chez lui mais
d'ailleurs je peux prouver parce que tu
as des dre à sonia rykiel
qui donne tout ça là n'ont jamais dormi
chez toi
je vais pas renier
et du coup donc on a passé un bon moment
et caetera et le lendemain matin il m'a
un peu mise comme une malpropre à la
porte j'avais trois étages peu importe
avec quelqu'un ou 5e je sais plus non
quel combat alors pourquoi dû transpirer
ziem 5e et voilà donc pouvoir même qu'il
pourra vous êtes là soit mais du coup je
continue non mais parce qu'on est on est
un peu près six matches
en fait cela semble un on a échangé nos
numéros qui m'a dit qu'ils étaient
pressés je sais pas quoi vous n'êtes pas
revu voilà tarek est ce que vous avez
envie juste en face de moi je ne
demandais pas son numéro et de la donner
c'est toi mon avis il a l'âme et
non c'est pas vu alors tarek est ce que
oui ou non vous avez invité mais jamais
de la vie jamais de la vie en fait si je
suis là aujourd'hui c'est bon pour
savoir en fait pourquoi ça s'est mal
passé enfin qu'est ce qui s'est passé
peut-être que tu m'as marié pinsonneault
pas mais je te jure on m'a proposé de
faire le dîner je ne pouvais pas j'ai
dit non je ne peux pas il ya mon
attachée de presse qu'est la mélodie
aller aux mélodies est-ce que c'était
une blague ouest m
les déplacements c'est vous qui le veut
donner des infos non même pas c'est
julien ruty c'est julien requis on me
dit dans l'oreillette du tout et je suis
heureux dans ses draps merci